Vamos por aquí,
que ahora yo también le voy a explicar un
poquito cómo vamos a hacer,
estructurar lo que es la llamada,
si le parece y así con cualquier cosa.
¿Usted me va parando y me va y le vamos
resolviendo las dudas, vale?
En este caso le explicaré quiénes somos,
la metodología, los docentes,
el plan de estudios y todo lo referente
al tema de admisiones, costes económicos.
También lo que comentamos de las plazas
con ayudas económicas.
Y en caso de querer continuar,
pues comentarle la doble titulación
internacional.
¿Usted me comentó que nos había conocido
por redes sociales, verdad? ¿Es correcto?
Vale,
de acuerdo y ha podido mirar un poquito
de nosotros. ¿Quiénes somos?
Nuestra página web sí pude entrar y viene
bastante amplio el el la oferta académica.
Es una Universidad de renombre que tiene
bastante trayectoria y es una.
Es una entidad que tiene un peso sobre la
formación en este mundo de maestrías,
incluso en el parte de los de los
diplomados de especialización. ¿Vale,
y este que estaba buscando con el máster?
¿Hay alguna habilidad que quiera pulir o
algún algún punto fuerte a desarrollar?
Pues he pensado bastante en la analítica
a través de base de datos.
Vale, eso me gusta.
¿Pudo mirar las herramientas con las que
contaba el programa? Sí,
perfecto es las las herramientas que pude
observar.
Acá me llamaron bastante las las los soft
skills que le llaman acá y las hot kids,
la capacidad de trabajo y también los
elementos que están relacionados. El el.
También me llamó la atención la
metodología.
Donde hay casos de estudios hay clases de
en directo a los Boot Camps también
correcto YY los los software que se van a
usar,
pero estoy viendo que trabajan con Google
y con correcto. ¿Sí,
también esos son conocidos,
pero los pero nosotros sí, no los conozco,
vale? Bueno,
así lo podemos mirar todo más
detalladamente.
¿Y había usted dado usted online
anteriormente o es la primera vez?
¿Ya lo he hecho ya ya lo he hecho,
tengo un diplomado en una entidad que se
llama Avent Business School,
es completamente a distancia, Ah bien,
entonces ya sabes más o menos 1 poquito
cómo funciona? Sí, sí, perfecto,
pues hecho, sí, pues mire,
le voy a compartir si le parece lo que es
mi pantalla y así vamos dando por la por
la web un paseo le voy mostrando y con
cualquier cosa, cualquier duda,
pues me va deteniendo usted y vamos
haciendo más hincapié a los puntos
fuertes.
A ver,
a ver ahora cuando cuando vea usted la
pantalla me lo me avisa y así,
ya que a mí en el momento que la comparta
ya se me quita la la sur y ya a ver muy
bien y deja, ahora ya está, ya voy,
ya ya puedo ver.
Perfecto, estupendo. Mire,
déjeme un segundín que vengo por aquí.
Bueno o b s somos la primera Escuela de
Negocios a nivel online del mundo.
¿Tenemos vinculación con la V,
que es la Universidad de Barcelona?
Nosotros formamos parte de Grupo Planeta.
No sé si usted lo conoce, no todo bien.
Grupo Planeta tiene 3 grandes grupos,
lo que es la editorial planeta que a lo
mejor ha oído hablar de las enciclopedias,
los libros, sí, eso sí, correcto,
la escuela de formación,
que en este caso seríamos nosotros,
que contamos con más de 21 escuelas
diferentes de tipos diferentes de
formación y en la última audiovisual,
no sé si le suena la plataforma 3 media.
No,
pero sí estoy familiarizado con lo
audiovisual. Eso sí, vale.
Entonces nosotros estábamos buscando una
alternativa de la formación presencial,
alejada del modelo de formación de
distancia.
La metodología que nosotros utilizamos es
cien por cien online.
¿Las clases no son pregrabadas,
serían en directo, de acuerdo?
El contexto educativo E o b s tiene una
evaluación continua, sin exámenes finales.
Sobre todo es trabajar en un contexto
colaborativo y participativo.
Básicamente lo que hacemos es trabajar
con actividades prácticas acompañadas del
profesor.
Lo que haremos al final en muchas
materias será pediros desde el inicio de
curso que analicéis unos materiales
contenidos y a partir de este análisis de
datos participéis en diferentes
actividades,
ya sean foros de debate a través de un
canal.
Que tenemos establecido de la escuela
soluciones Unidas en común conjuntamente
con el profesor y luego poder recibir un
feedback en lo que es llamado de otra
forma,
sería la metodología el caso que no sé si
ha escuchado hablar perfecto.
Lo que hacemos es trabajar con una
masterclass a la semana de unos 90
minutos que en horario del Salvador sería
más o menos al mediodía.
Esta clase siempre quedan grabadas.
Y si por cualquier caso,
coincidiera con algún horario que usted
no puede estar atento en ese momento,
siempre quedan grabadas en diferido por
si está de viaje o trabajando o cualquier
cosa. A partir de aquí,
la evaluación también estará basada en
actividades prácticas,
ejercicios aplicables.
La mayoría de ellas suelen ser los casos
semanales y se trabaja tanto grupalmente
como personalmente.
No sé si usted ha oído hablar de la
metodología studenon que la tenemos
patentada. ¿Lo que hace es con eso, vale?
¿Mira a ver,
lo que hace es colocar al alumno en el
centro, de acuerdo? Y en este caso a ver,
déjeme 1 segundo que estaba intentando
poner aquí en la pantalla.
A ver aquí,
que a veces me lío con las páginas de de
Internet.
Lo que hace es colocar al centro de la
formación de manera activa,
pero siempre acompañado de 3 figuras
clave del director del Máster,
que controla y supervisa todo lo que
sucede,
el profesor que en este momento esté en
activo por la asignatura que toque,
y el Project Project manager académico,
que será su tutor personalizado.
Desde el inicio del curso hasta el final,
la mayoría de docentes son directivos y
ceos de empresas conocidas
internacionales.
A partir del sexto mes se haría el
trabajo final de máster,
que estará alineado con todas las
necesidades reales del mercado laboral.
Al final,
podrá desarrollar un proyecto y su
posterior implementación inmediata en la
empresa o en el emprendimiento.
Y durante todo este transcurso del
proyecto contará con el apoyo del
supervisor o del tutor académico,
que en este caso se le se le asigna al
principio de curso.
Hasta que alguna duda alguna,
cosa que se va explicando bastante bien.
Entiendo que los docentes también son son
empresarios. ¿Correcto?
Mire a ver por aquí,
pudo ver en el plan de estudios que le
aparecía los docentes.
Ahora lo muestro,
pero sin ningún problema.
Mire también el tema de reconocimientos a
nivel ranking mundiales.
Estamos en en grandes reconocimientos
como las Forbes, en el final Times,
en el universal.
Y no sé si usted ha hablado del Quest
Star Rating Systems. ¿No, no, no,
no estoy informado, vale?
Pues sería el ranking,
el cual nos ha dado las 5 estrellas a
nivel castellano parlante a nivel de
español,
que estamos en el primer posicionamiento.
Después como partners académicos tenemos
la Universidad de Barcelona y la Unie de
Madrid.
Por eso en el al final de máster se
recibe una doble titulación por parte de
o b s Business School, que somos nosotros.
Y de nuestro partner académico de la
Universidad.
Después aquí le voy a mostrar lo que es
el Directorio Alumni,
que tenemos un club de alumnos en cada 1
de los países que más alumnos tenemos,
que hacen clubs de networking a ver.
Mire,
aquí también es una herramienta que suelo
compartir con con vosotros porque es
bastante interesante para que no sé si
usted tiene LinkedIn. Sí, sí, pues sí.
Mire,
pues aquí nos puede buscar a nosotros de
acuerdo,
y aquí hay una pestañita que pone
antiguos alumnos.
Usted aquí puede ir a mirar. Por ejemplo,
usted puede que poner aquí palabra clave
como por El Salvador.
Entonces aquí le aparecerán antiguos
alumnos del Salvador,
por si usted quisiera pedir alguna
referencia o ponerse en contacto con para
buscar al final referencias o o también,
por ejemplo, de su máster en sí,
el que se había interesado.
Y al final también cuando tienes otras
visiones.
¿Pues siempre va bien la la comparación,
vale?
Estos serían en todos nuestros países los
que impartimos y ahora pasaríamos a ver
lo que es el máster.
A ver que me va fatal el el ratón.
Ahora aquí perfecto.
Mire aquí también donde le envié el plan
de estudios aquí donde pone los los
docentes.
Tiene también su perfil de LinkedIn por
si le quiere echar una ojeada. Ah,
muy bien, muy bien, vale.
¿A ver, que vea el plan de estudios,
que es que como es es tan extenso, vale?
Mire,
hay algo que le haya llamado la atención,
algo que quiera resaltar,
alguna duda que le surja.
De momento todo va bien,
todo no tengo duda,
no tengo ninguna pregunta,
le sigo prestando atención, perfecto,
pues mire,
le comento un poquito sobre el máster en
sí.
Es un programa de 12 meses. ¿De acuerdo?
Se va haciendo,
se va cursando una asignatura mensual,
no se colapsan dos asignaturas entre sí,
es decir,
primero empezaríamos por la primera
asignatura en el bloqueo,
una arquitectura en vía,
y en el siguiente mes sería estrategia
digital,
el siguiente mes análisis de datos y así
sucesivamente hasta llegar al mes 6,
que sería el de tecnologías Big Data y
cloud.
Que entonces ahí se empezaría a hacer lo
que es el trabajo de final de máster.
Vale,
al final el máster ese está avalado por
la Universidad de Barcelona,
como le comentaba que antes te reciben
dos cartones. Doble titulación hay,
en este caso el de Business Intelligence
va con la de Universidad de Barcelona,
no con la de Madrid,
de acuerdo ya muy bien,
ya aprenderá en este caso el alumno.
Arquitecturas datos de Warehouse,
ELT Data Analystic data Discovery,
visualización con herramientas líderes
como Power BI, Quick Tableau, Big Data,
gestión de proyectos con con B I y B a
Business Analysis, Minería de datos.
Después tenemos las los bootcamps y esto
empezaría de cara a la semana que viene,
que son optativos tanto de de I a de data
Storytelling, Python.
También hacemos simulaciones con casos
reales con el uso del software
empresarial.
El perfil de la media del estudiante del
alumno nuestro son profesionales,
con una media de 12 años de experiencia y
provenientes de sectores como banca,
tecnología, salud, telecomunicaciones.
Para que al final pueda haber una buena
cohesión de clase y siempre poder estar
aprendiendo los unos de los otros.
Es una un conglomerado diverso,
heterogéneo, de de de disciplina,
donde todos aprendemos de todo correcto.
Al final lo que se obtiene sería una
doble titulación con o b s más
Universidad de Barcelona el acceso a
todas las herramientas del mercado.
Una red internacional de más de 42000
alumnos.
Una empleabilidad potenciada a un 20%
aproximadamente del salario cuando
transcursar unos estudios y
certificaciones opcionales como podrían
ser scrum practitioner, entre otras.
Después, como le comentaba,
todo este tema es online,
pero para el final de todo.
Tendríamos lo que se llama la global
inversión week,
que sería una semana de de graduación
aquí en Barcelona. Es opcional,
pero bueno, siempre va bien.
También como para conocer a los
compañeros,
conocer a los profesores y hay varios
talleres en esa semana que le entran
dentro.
Le vienen incluidos que sería un curso de
inteligencia artificial con Google,
la visita de bueno del campo de fútbol
que de Barcelona que está.
¿Como tiene bastante inteligencia
artificial, cómo se ha construido?
Porque es nuevo de este año y después
habría diferentes cursos y el el alumni
Day Welcome y después ya por último día
tendríamos la graduación.
¿Esto lo que le comento que es opcional,
pero siempre usted ha venido alguna vez
aquí a Barcelona? Sí,
ya he tenido la la oportunidad de estar
ahí. ¿Y qué qué tal? ¿Qué le ha parecido?
Me enamoré completamente.
Es una ciudad que me sacó de los ojos,
que me dejó muchísimo, muy ordenada, muy,
pero muy amigable. No hay donde perderse.
Tiene espacios abiertos,
bastante recreación y sobre todo,
ahí está el equipo de fútbol.
Me gusta mucho.
Sí,
por eso cuando cuando lo acababa de
mencionar, se me abrieron los ojos. Sí,
sí, sí.
Es que mucha gente le cuando le cuando
decimos las excursiones,
que una de ellas es esa, dicen,
qué bien a ella cambia todo. Claro,
por supuesto, el tema de, por ejemplo,
del del trabajo de final de Master,
lo que le comentaba algunos,
imaginad que se puede hacer el final,
el proyecto.
¿Para la empresa en la que 1 trabaje,
es algún caso real de acuerdo? Mire a ver,
vamos a mirar.
¿Ha escuchado hablar usted de la
plataforma Blackboard?
Ya ya le ya le incluso la usé una vez. Ah,
mire, perfecto,
porque con esta trabajamos nosotros
también. A ver, déjeme un segundín,
es bastante fácil de de manejar,
por así decirlo.
Y de aquí y diríamos en carrier hay
muchos bootcamps también que se pueden
hacer opcionalmente en el transcurso de
pues de la vida,
porque en este caso la la formación es
ilimitada, es para siempre, es decir,
este campo siempre usted lo tendrá
abierto.
Y si necesita un workshop de reinvención
profesional, un Project mentoring.
Se puede inscribir a cualquiera de los
bootcamps en cualquier momento de su
etapa.
No es necesario que esté cursando
anualmente con en en en este año cursado
con nosotros,
que también es bastante curioso después.
¿Y eso dígame?
El acceso a la plataforma es.
Vitalicio es sí,
por siempre o solamente durante durante
no.
El acceso a la plataforma es es de por
vida. Es vitalicio, es decir,
usted tendrá el año cursado el máster,
pero lo que son los complementos de los
bootcamps lo tiene vitalicio.
Lo tiene para toda la vida.
Si usted dentro de un par de años dice.
Mire,
es que necesito un workshop de liderazgo
porque es que lo hice,
pero como que se me ha perdido un poco,
pues puede volver y gestionarlo de nuevo.
Ah, qué bueno,
qué bueno vale a ver por aquí.
¿Qué más tengo para enseñarle? Mire.
Ahora le voy a pasar aquí y después le le
comenté la llamada, la primera llamada.
Nosotros trabajamos con proceso de
admisión,
no tenemos matriculación abierta,
es decir,
si a usted realmente después le
interesara el cursar el máster con
nosotros la los pasos a seguir serían
pues la primera que sería la solicitud de
la admisión.
Que es el el paso previo a conocernos
después,
la entrevista personal que es en el
momento que donde estaríamos nosotros
ahora mismo. Después se entregaría,
en el caso de interesarle la
documentación de admisión,
que sería pues un currículum,
una hoja de vida, el D, n I o Pasaporte,
la fotocopia del Título universitario y
una carta de motivación.
¿Usted alguna vez ha hecho alguna carta
de motivación?
Sí, ya he tenido la oportunidad. Sí, vale.
Entonces todos estos documentos se
entregarían al admisiones y después se
evaluaría que le darían una respuesta el
la solución en 2 días. Vale,
si tiene alguna duda hasta el momento, no,
no, no, no, solamente hay una,
hay una frase que.
¿Mostró usted que era de de acuerdo?
Ya no me voy a acordar,
que se se me olvidó en el momento
preguntarle en 1 de los de los
lineamientos que usted mostró en el en 1
de los archivos de texto,
ya ya me voy a acordar algo de los dónde
estábamos en el plan de estudio, sí,
por ahí está, por ahí a verlo,
vamos para allá.
Después del primer bloque que usted
especificó,
donde se veía la arquitectura del vale de
todo eso, por ahí,
por ahí hay una palabra de acuerdo,
que fue lo que que me iba a tener acceso,
iba a tener acceso a podía tener acceso a
todas esas cosas, a las herramientas.
Me dijo, vale, a ver.
Google hago a W por ahí a ver,
a ver que caiga yo también es que ahora
mismo no sé a ver alguna de las
herramientas puede ser por ahí.
De de minería de datos de Business
Analystics Analystics.
Es que no sé hacia abajo ahí un poquito
más abajo,
si es tan amable donde dice perfil bajo
más para abajo de aquí sí un poquito,
pero si gusta contigo ya me voy a acordar
para no ir a.
Su su línea, que él tiene preparada,
lamento haber sido así, no, no, claro,
pero al final este tiempo es para usted.
Entonces, si usted tiene cualquier duda,
sí lo podemos ir resolviendo. Gracias,
gracias,
ya voy a recordar cuál es la palabra para
decirle, bueno,
y hasta aquí más o menos todo por eso le
comentaba, a ver los en cuanto a la.
¿Al a la inversión,
cuánto es el costo para poder poder poder
iniciar con ustedes?
Le va mejor en en dólares, en euros.
El en la primera moneda en dólares,
mira el precio del máster son €7700,
entonces serían 8966 dólares.
Esto más o menos entraba en lo que usted
estaba barajando a la hora del máster.
Sí, sí, sí.
Correcto es lo que he contemplado para
invertir en información.
Sí es vale de acuerdo. Entonces, mire,
nosotros lo hacemos tanto de manera al
contado que en este caso se le reduce.
Bueno,
tiene un descuento en el la en el coste
final o si no se podría hacer también de
manera.
Primeramente hacer la inscripción y
después hacerlo mensualmente sin
intereses.
¿A usted cómo le quedaría más cómodo?
Pues me daría más cómodo la segunda
alternativa, vale a ver, mire,
entonces se podría quedar para hacer más
o menos 1 idea a ver, déjeme un segundín.
Es la cantidad que está bien proyectada
entre entre 12 pagos. Sí voy a mirar,
voy a ir ahora a la calculadora de costos,
que así se lo puedo decir todo más todo
tal cual mira sería y así lo cambio a los
dólares y es más fácil.
Mire, a ver,
deme un segundín ahora y lo tenía puesto
en otra moneda y cambia completamente.
Mire,
pues se podría quedar en este caso en
cuotas, por ejemplo,
si lo hiciéramos a 12 meses,
como el máster dura 12 meses.
Así se se podría quedar en este caso en
436 dólares mensualmente.
O K perfecto.
Ya ya puedo tomar 111 segundo análisis
para tomar mi mi decisión. Vale también,
no sé si le había comentado que
contábamos con plazas con ayuda económica
y ahora al ser la apertura de
convocatoria,
también contamos con esas plazas que hay
un un menor, una menor a con tía,
pero todavía todavía quedan.
En este caso,
las plazas de ayuda económica.
A usted le podrían interesar, sí,
De hecho, sí, vale, entonces, mire,
en este caso,
si finalmente le interesara que usara el
máster, hiciera la carta de motivación.
Ahí sería importante que es el que lo
pusiera que le gustaría recibir las
ayudas económicas. ¿En este caso, cómo?
Perdón, no, no, perdón, no.
Vale,
en este caso con bueno las ayudas
económicas se podría quedar,
déjeme un segundín se podría quedar un
importe total de 6150,
23 dólares del total del total.
Yo todo esto también se lo voy a enviar
por correo para que lo tenga, vale, Ah,
bueno, vale,
y así lo tiene todo mejor YY después le
puede echar un ojo tranquilamente.
En este caso las ayudas serían correcto,
serían las ayudas serían menos 2418
dólares y se quedaría una cuota final.
A ver, espera un segundín. Ojalá no tenga,
venga, venga.
Mire,
se tendrían que dar en este caso el 10%
de la inscripción de al principio,
que querían 615 dólares y eso después se
le descuenta del valor final del del
precio del máster. De acuerdo, ahora todo.
Yo ahora todo esto le le pasaré un Excel
al correo electrónico,
vale para que lo tenga todo bien
estructurado y usted se lo pueda revisar
tranquilamente y de cara a mañana.
¿No sé si tendría un espacio para que
podamos resolver las dudas que se le
hayan ocasionado de 5 o 10 minutos de
mañana se me dificulta,
pero sí puedo ser el día jueves, vale? Sí,
sí puedo.
En este caso, el jueves tenemos admisión,
o sea, tenemos la reunión con la, con la,
con este, con el Comité de Admisiones.
Entonces,
no sé si usted lo tendría más o menos
pensado.
De cara al jueves sería bueno porque le
podríamos dar la resolución de si entran
en las plazas con ayudas económicas.
Yo diría que sí,
entonces si me manda la información yo no
analizo y después ya podemos conversar ya
en forma perfecto.
Pues entonces yo ahora le enviaré por
correo todo lo que hemos hablado hasta el
momento. Le pasaré tanto los los costes,
todo lo que es la bueno,
todo lo que hemos hablado en la reunión
para que lo tenga estructurado y con
cualquier cosita,
pues estamos en contacto mañana.
¿El día jueves me pongo en contacto con
usted, le va bien para esta hora?
Sí, a la misma hora, 1230 perfecto.
Y Así pues, ponemos a puntos en común,
resolvemos las dudas que se hayan quedado
YY si finalmente mañana usted está seguro
de que sí que quiere realizar la el
máster,
si me podría avisar mañana para poderle
darle la resolución de las ayudas
económicas el jueves,
que sería que si contamos con dos veces
que podamos hacerlo.
A las puestas de ayudas económicas vale,
perfecto que hagamos de esa forma,
cuente con mi respuesta para el día de
mañana y pues lo mismo el jueves para
aclarar la clase perfecto,
pues hacemos así con cualquier cosita,
estamos en contacto,
tienen mi teléfono y mi correo
electrónico, yo lo tengo,
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo. ¿Esther,
le puedo llamar a esta tuta? Claro,
por supuesto, bueno.
¿Gracias por su tiempo, por su amabilidad,
por su gentileza y por, sobre todo,
su tiempo, que es lo más valioso, no?
Hombre, muchísimas gracias a usted.
Igualmente que tenga buen día igualmente
para usted.
Estamos en contacto hasta luego adéu.